but I fell asleep outside today for a
little while oh yeah on your porch yeah
this is the second time in like four
days your dad was out there waiting for
the weed guy to come he told me be at
3:30 I went out there about a quarter to
three because it was beautiful I [__]
fell
up you're all right not really I did a
bang it and came out here and got some
sun and it's all over what's happening
You Beautiful Savages it's Tuesday
February the 6th the checkin is brought
to you by Blue Chu listen guys it
doesn't matter how old you are good sex
is good sex blue Chu is here to make it
awesome every time blue Chu is online
service that sends chewable tablets
right to your door with the same active
ingredients as Viagra Calis and Levitra
at half the course take a tablet anytime
day and night so you're always ready to
get the party started let me tell you
something I love these because you they
come in individual pouches you can put
them in your little wallet and when it's
time to sling you're always prepared
you're like a [__] General your
Cannon's loaded you know what I'm saying
everything is done online with blue chew
no awkward doctor visits no waiting in
line at the pharmacy Blue chw packaging
is discreet but your package will be
unmistakable so do me a favor blue Chu
wants to help you have better sex
discover options at
blue.com chew it and do it here's the
special deal for checkin listeners try
blue Chu for free when you press code
Joey j o e y a checkout again free when
you press code Joey at checkout and just
pay $5 for shipping that's blu.com promo
code Joey to receive your first month
free visit blu.com for more details and
important safety information and thank
you blue Tru for sponsoring the podcast
listen if you don't know about blue get
your [__] together all right your dick
will be as hard as these missiles
they're sending over there you'll be
making everybody very [__] happy
including Mama the cat whatever whoever
wants it now the Checker is also brought
to you
by the freeze pipe listen when you when
we're done with looking stupid and
getting coughin attacks every time we
smoke cut the [__] out with freeze pipe
why I want to look like Lee you ever see
Lee smoke the old bongs he's fumbling
he's spitting and [__] not what freeze
pipe he doesn't freeze pipe is
tremendous they make freezable pipes
bubblers and bongs and more that cool
smoke down by over 300 Dees I got one in
the garage right now I got the [__]
chamber in the freezer with the meat and
the Italian Ice
I go out there I change the water I put
my piece in there I grind up my [__]
death reefer and next thing you know
baboom just pop that baby in the freezer
for an hour and then smoke passes
through the chamber and instantly cooled
down you won't be coughing your eye
won't come out and when people come over
you'll be the best host in town and have
one ready when company's over American
owned with over a 100,000 100,000 happy
customers freeze pipe is your solution
to smoke like royalty without paying a
king's Ransom shop right now at the free
pipe.com again the freeze pipe.com
pressing code Diaz d a z I'm Gonna Get
You 10% off your entire order and that's
a big number these days that's the free
pipe.com code Diaz for 10% off order
today and get free free shipping and say
goodbye to killing your lungs
Forever Without further Ado let's get
this party started Jack turn off your
TVs run for your lives it's over they
didn't put you on this planet just to
give up if Uncle Joey could do it I can
rule the world that's what you got to be
thinking welcome back
[Music]
to
what up moo beautiful Tuesday February
the 6 here look at this look good I got
some sun this weekend I know you were
saying the [__] balcony
tremendous that that's like a real good
what do you what were you in like a a
chair or like a do you you don't have a
hammock do you you're not a hammock I
got a hammock but I got stuck in there
two years ago
I what do you mean you got stuck in the
H Oh I thought I was being [__] cute
I went out there one day it was a
beautiful day I lay my wife's like we
got a hammock now so I went out there
got on a hammock the problem was I
couldn't get out of there I mean I was
[__] stuck I got into the middle of
the hammock I couldn't get out I had to
yell for her she had to come out with
mercy and they had to save me it was
[__] tremendous so I don't get
hammock no more I got two rocking chairs
in the front of the house yeah and I
just sit out there me and my wife will
talk we'll drink [__] iced tea out
there talk [__] for hours it's [__]
great to have it really is everybody on
my block says we all wanted that house
because it got so much sun in the front
you know oh yeah it's great to have a
little little place to hang out or just
do something I'm not I don't like doing
a lot Outdoors but just just be
outdoors smoke a joint or even just like
like you said to just relax is nice I
tell you you go my back yard it's
[__] anarctica back there it's
[__]
freezing freezing in my backyard in
comparison to the front of the house
that's always getting beat up by Sun
there ain't a [__] there ain't a
strand of sunlight it covers the grass
and stuff but under the balcony under
the kitchen there's no sun under there
you step out there you [__] freeze to
death you know yeah you were wearing a
winter coat when I came over on Saturday
night oh yeah
bro once the sun goes down it's all over
but the shout it's a different [__]
and it was it was cool this weekend it
was warm you had a nice warm weekend
it's getting cold now at night like it's
dropping and you know what bothers me
the most about all this Chit Chat what
but I grew up in this [__] weather I
walked miles in this weather I drank
beers in this weather you know I
remember falling asleep on a qualude one
night in the coldest night in January
and still having fingers than next day
with no gloves on you
know and it's crazy how I go out now for
two minutes and I'm [__] it it
baffles me that I lived in Aspen I skied
I I fell on wet snow I fell you know and
I go outside I can't even go into a cold
pool no it just bothers the [__] out of
me because you're not used to like the
cold anymore after like 30 years in La
whatever it was I don't know what the
[__] happened man my bones just got
warmed up I go to a cow therapy place I
do the red light sauna I have not yet to
[__] go in that freezer and I need
you did it all the time in LA didn't you
yeah because it's 80 degrees out so it's
like [__] heaven in those things but
when it's it's only warm six months of a
year and it's [__] you know it just
it's different we change I don't know we
[__] I wasn't in in uh the jersey for
that long but even in the city I like I
would like I I cuz I had a sweatshirt
and a jacket on I was was sweating on
the train like it was it like doing all
like I did like I think I did like
20,000 steps I bet you did one day it
was just [__] it it was [__]
awesome but I was surprised to be
sweating in I guess it was February but
it was uh every time I go I just I love
New York more it was was [__] do man
New York is cool I got to go into the
city tomorrow oh yeah ex yeah I'm
excited I'm go do a podcast talk to some
boys I'm going to start going in maybe
Wednesday night my friend's doing a show
in the city you know but a lot of
interesting things happened man I I
didn't know listen I don't know what's
going on I know that [__] America's
bombing the hoochies or something like
that now
yeah but I also read this morning that
and and I think this is great that Shane
Gillis is hosting Saturday Night Live
yeah you know it's funny that when they
fire him before the pandemic right in
the beginning of the pandemic I think it
was like 19 2019 is what I saw yeah and
it was over a podcast he did where he
said some racial stuff about some Asian
people you
know and they got rid of him and look
what he did he didn't
[__] die he he rose to the top you
know and whatever cancelling means or
whatever any of that stuff
is when the cream Rises you're not going
to stop it with it cancellation unless
you hit an old lady in the head and
raped her you
know yeah I mean
that's you hit her in the head with a
hammer and you rape her but I mean you
know some of these some of these
cancellations have been [__]
weird but his cancellation was early
on it was for something he had said on a
podcast which listen if you look up
those Church podcasts
I said a lot of bad stuff on those
podcasts okay and some of the stuff I'm
not proud of and if you look at it you
go what made me say it okay I'm in the
moment I'm
flowing and you happen that something
slips out or something like that anybody
who knows me knows what my intentions
were and when you're doing a podcast in
2019 and maybe the podcast was a year
old or something I don't know you know
things Chang very quickly and people who
weren't on board got thrown off board
for no reason but these people didn't
give up you know there's I can name 10
comics that including myself that they
tried to Jade them off but you're not
doing nothing to me because hard
work is more than your [__] stupid
critique of something I said years ago
right when some has to pick when
somebody has to pick a scab from years
ago go it it's not
good it's not I don't know if you saw
someone made a video I think Louis uh
Gomez retweeted it it was like everyone
who talk not everyone but a lot of the
big people who talk [__] about Shane
like with like the headlines and like
now like they got fired or they don't
work there anymore or like their show
failed and now Shane is is H and I don't
know if you saw this like a within the
like last two weeks Bud Light signed him
too
so like in the last week or two it's
been like two of the biggest things in
the whole world want to work with
him and that clip didn't go
away listen man Redemption is
a it's a great
feeling when you did something and it
was a mistake and some people lost their
[__] panties over it for no reason
whatsoever it had nothing to do with
them or
whatever and then uh you come back and
go listen I'm back [__] and I got my
thumb on you cuz I know all the
[__] that talk
[__] so now you now you got to bring me
water and coffee
and my toes and then you got the other
chines kid on Sat Night Live that you
know he distances himself away from
everybody you know last week it was
Haley the week before was [__] uh
somebody else was on the show and he
didn't want to be close to him you know
who the [__] do people think they are
anymore well and I
mean when you compare like podcasting to
standup like when you're on
stage all like all your brain is
thinking about is like say something
funny so like it like when you first
started stand uh the podcast I mean was
it like similar like it's not like
you're thinking of like oh is this 100%
accurate or oh is this what I believe in
like were you when you were starting the
podcast we were just like is this funny
like that's what I imagine
happened my first three months of
podcasting was like everybody else you
know you don't even know what you're
doing he had no idea what you're
doing you got somebody who you thought
would be a good
guest and you did the best you could
sometimes you got
conversations I enjoyed podcasting from
2010 to 2019 when we got out of that
office well the the last six months in
the office were rough but it was really
an enjoyment
because you get to talk and tell your
truths and talk about your life and
whatever and then you know it was it was
great I mean for both sides because we
were just
learning everybody was just [__]
learning and then 5 years later the
podcast police comes
out you and they're [__] talking [__]
and it was listen man the podcast police
of people who just want to be Rogan and
they can't figure it out it's very sad
when it's become I can't imagine what's
coming down his way now with this second
deal from Spotify you
know but God bless him God bless him he
opened up a new Range you know this was
a
great uh thing podcasting now
everybody's doing it it's taking the the
thrill away the dangerousness you know
right I enjoyed podcasting because it
was very dangerous like you could just
you know one minute we were talking next
minute we're doing a hit
acid you know we're talking to a hooker
and her pimp from [__] uh Nevada I
mean it was just so
surreal but then like again it's like
everything else the podcast police came
out and oh you you know your set is
dirty this and and it's like they never
understood what this was really about
it's just two [__] three four people
talking for an hour as a form of
entertainment some people are better
than that than others you know it's so
funny I did that podcast I don't know 90
days with Felicia
okay and we were kind of scratching the
surface we were doing this we were doing
that and till this day I still remember
when it happened when I just said that I
a tell you about the hooker I
mugged and I and and I still remember
she had the microphone
blocks the thing you can't spit on the
mic and at one point after telling the
story I looked from behind the mic and
she was [__] blown the [__] away like
her face was like
and that was the day I knew that I did a
CAT Williams when Cat Williams talked
about Michael Jackson and he got the
room crazy right that's the same thing I
did that day and I liked it I told the
story that I
knew would either kill me or [__]
save
me and it saved
me and I think like getting back to like
what like Shane and stuff isn't that
like kind of the goal
yes even even even if like you are going
to offend some people it's only going to
like when you get cancelled it only
shows more people who think you the way
you do who you are so like that as I I
don't know Shane I've never said one
word to him in my entire life but I
would imagine that SNL thing H helped
him it did he put out a special on
YouTube he was the first guy to hit like
a million in like a [__]
day and he took chances
because he had nothing to
lose and the Press didn't really ride
him for being a racist or anything you
know he was doing the Trump impression
and I think that all [__] got Reed up
into one but Shane's a great comic he's
right now he's really happening as one
of the young guys I mean I really like
what he's
doing he's a fun guy he loves to [__]
drink and party you know he's down there
with Rogan having a great time in Austin
during the
week and uh that's the spot a lot of
young Comics want to be at you know I
mean I I know you're looking at that
going wow I wish I could do this in 10
15 12 you know and you never know Lee
it's all up to you right comic you're
your biggest [__]
enemy you know it's like Shadow Boxing
when you watch Creed and he tells the
kid to shadow box he goes this is going
to be a toughest his
opponent that guy that that guy controls
it all you know and it's really it's the
truth you know I was telling you on the
phone
that Saturday when you came here after
the dojo comedy and we got [__] up oh
yeah I got some more of these gummies
here all right can you at least tell me
how much those really are now first of
all I found out to my uh cuz I went on
their
website they Delta 9
okay and 25
servings you know with Delta 9 I can't
really tell it said CBD oh CBD
preserving less than 10 THC
preserving 25
milligrams okay well and how much was
the the BX that I had who knows they're
in a box exactly of those mixed 50s
hundreds 25s
yeah every time you stick your hand in
there you got a different [__]
surprise that's not what you said up
until right now no I told you it's a 50
because the the angrier
[Music]
ones this was the LA no I think I have
two more 50s left of course you that
night because you said you were gonna
eat another 50 but at mushroom caps yeah
those mushrooms are fire yes they
are holy [__] yes they are I F I [__]
P I had a like a real long talk with my
I was I fell asleep in the bathroom a
couple of times on door I just I like
leaned I would wake up the Delta 9 the
ABX and the mushroom caps you didn't
know whether you were coming or going it
was like me when I did Rogan between the
the chewing and tobacco the whiskey the
reefer and the [__] smelling
Sals I'm on a different [__] level
yeah I'm on a different time zone you
know what I'm saying you don't even know
it then but when you leave there and
wake up the next morning you're like
yeah I was [__] up last night I'm
still [__] up
now oh that's because you I'm not in
training you don't train no one can
train for that yes you can no you can't
right now the Russians [__] sat me
down and said bring me to your leader
who will give you THC I got him for two
days for but yeah even if you wanted to
give them you'd probably take the free
Edibles like but no one's ever no
Russia's never going to do that why
would they just not kill you why what
are they gonna give you Edibles for what
about the hoies what about these B the
hoochies over
there listen I don't think the hoties if
you gave a hooti an edible they freak
out what they've never had an edible
before what if China invades Taiwan and
you got to go over there and you gives
you a $10 bag of heroin you're not g to
do it people shooting missiles and [__]
yeah so you'll be prepared that's why
you're always in training always popping
six like today I opened up with four
abx's and I just woke up that I was like
I ain't got time for this I gotta get
ready for my brother Lee I just stuck my
hand in there four of them came out boom
they could be 400 milligrams they could
be 800
milligrams but wouldn't you like to know
not really what do you want to knowbody
wants to know what what is it is it
going to change your everybody wants
it's GNA change a lot it could be
anywhere from 200 to 800 that's a big
change sit there at 4 in the mornings
with the lights on and you're staring
you got a bag of popcorn all over the
floor and chocolate buns yeah does it if
I tell you all right Lee it was only 200
milligrams it gonna make you feel any
better it's not GNA make me feel better
but it explain some stuff I scared
people on the
train two different people moved away
from
me
two different people like N I can't sit
next to that for four hours why what
were you doing well I I got the and I
was on the nicer train like the asella
for the first time which was great I
don't remember much but I got then I
have a week's worth of clothes so I was
putting the suitcase up and this tall
guy had to help me because I was also
[__] up like it's amazing that I even
made it on the train by the way and I
put it up and he like sees me sit down
and take all my [__] off and he just
like turned around found another one but
then it got busy and like cuz I got on
in Jersey we got to Manhattan and this
dude sat next to me for like a stop is
and then when I went up to use the
bathroom I came back and he was gone
like he just he was like no we didn't
get to another stop so he definitely
didn't like got off the plane I mean not
get off the train but yeah I was dude I
just didn't I couldn't stop eating I got
a cheese plate on the [__]
train I couldn't [__] oh my my God I
couldn't stop with the grapes and the
peanuts and
[__] you with three almonds I don't want
almonds put the almonds in the grape
like I'm Julia teesa hit me with the
goody good get go get that guda in that
atam yeah always give you they always
give you one crack or two light they did
why did I it's like dog go get the other
[__] cracker get me two to wash the
cracker down yeah there's always that
one pie piece of cheese that's
disgusting that you got to eat cuz
you're high it's like yellow jeda gotta
eat this [__] tooth breaker without a
[__]
cracker yeah you save it to the end yeah
they give you like a little Swiss a
little GAA and then they give you two
crackers three almonds and a grape and
I'm supposed to be [__] Tip Top my go
get the [__] go in the back and get the
rest of that cheese board let's cut this
[__] up Jack Jesus and I I
didn't prepare for the because I didn't
honestly I didn't think I was going to
see Saturday night CU like oh it's gonna
be I'm not gonna get back till midnight
I called you and you're like [__] it
every Saturday at midnight I and I
remember when I got and it was great and
we took it and you like listen I got to
go to sleep and you got to get home
before this stuff starts to kick in and
I honestly think that mushrooms might be
somehow connected to the universe
because they did wait until I got back
to my hotel but I also I never hit every
Green I hit every Green on the way home
from the hotel to the hotel I had every
green and then there's something about
New Jersey that I on like it's not like
a highway but an in between Highway when
you're coming in from like the side
streets they don't have ramps it's just
like you got to take a right from a stop
sign onto like basically a highway
people doing 60 and when you're a little
bit stoned that shit's
terrifying and L there was no one there
it was [__] what are you looking at
nothing oh my God yeah I just seeing
what I was saying you know I'm saying I
barely made it to your house like I
didn't I I had I like I never leave
packing till the last minute oh in the
morning look too good when you got here
I was gonna say just take to 4:30 relax
sit back watch some tennis you know
because you're not even gonna know what
you watch when you wake up you're gonna
yeah you just missed the Super Bowl
really you don't going on oh I had no
idea I couldn't even watch like people I
think I think they were scared cuz on
the train I like I couldn't even handle
looking at my phone like I just sort of
but I wasn't like you can't really sleep
on the train because like they're moving
and talking so I was just kind standing
up straight 7 milligrams and two
mushroom caps what the [__] first of all
you just admitted that it was at between
75 and
400 you no but you say that but the
highest one I have is 200 I got a 100
but not many left because you ate them
all and I had some 50s and I threw them
in the bunch so they had to be 1050s in
there maybe between 75 and 125 no you
weigh 50 yeah you weigh
75 or 125 that ain't enough and 25 your
ABX and then those mushrooms are just
you don't know what's in those caps I've
never had just two caps by the way I get
no credit from you I ate those with not
no not one problem I didn't making faces
and
[__] G to get the airplane bag I saw you
chewing and [__] stuttering in your
shoes and [__] but did I did I puke I
didn't even gag once honey for you no
you didn't puke yeah you wanted to give
me honey that was full of THC or other
mushrooms or something it was a grand of
mushrooms it's the same people you know
fun factories I'm sure I'm sure it's
great tastes great and helps but I'm not
adding more mushrooms to my mushroom
what's a gram on two caps what's it
going to do to you what again a lot what
do you mean what's it what's it gonna do
how's it going to deter you from your
mission that's what I'm saying I don't
want to know why ask
questions because you have to know what
you're taking when when my friend used
to go to those Satanic rituals they just
give you something when you take it they
give you something to drink you drink it
you see the devil and and you go home
but why you going to Satanic rituals
like that's not a good of you not me our
friend I'll tell you I know that I know
not you I hope not you
but you can't like you're using that as
an excuse of why you don't ask because
don't ask what do you want to know
what's the difference between 10
milligrams and 50 if I give it to you a
lot for people take yeah I talk to
people every week now about this if you
go from 10 to 50 that's like going from
you're lifting five pounds to you're
lifting 3
100b yes and
no yes and no you ain't lifting no was
[__] no I'm not but I'm also not eating
what do you I have a lot of experience
eating this many Edibles and not knowing
what is in the
package and you're still here I am still
here A matter you're a [__] soldier
of well no I'm not saying I'm gonna die
but I'm gonna say the up and up you know
what do you complain about no one's
complaining
I'm
just everybody needs to know everything
what time the plane get there what's the
size of the engine uh you know how many
people fit in the back what if what if
what what if you shut the [__] up get
high and mind your business look
straight at you don't want to know
nothing you wouldn't be on this [__]
plane anyway with the rest of these
retards oh be on a plane with the
[__] King of England with his little
prostate can flying around the [__]
world speaking of that I haven't even
got to tell you this yet I don't know
what it is about me but I picked the
wrong doctor he's a nice guy but I think
I have to find a new
doctor a he stuck a finger in your ass
no I get there he's a very nice guy he's
missing a tooth he's missing the front
tooth he and I don't know that should
have I should that I should have ended
with that one and I tried to keep a
straight face and he was a very it
seemed like nobody was talking about but
he was just that that tooth is an
interesting tooth to to be missing like
the the very front and then he Dro like
he whenever I tell people like what do
you do so I I I've been maybe it's a
mistake to tell people you're trying to
be a comic I try to you know make small
talk don't bring that up no more I'm not
going to he started he started telling
me his own jokes yeah and like he
dropped he dropped [__] he just like
in the middle of like getting my
vitals he's like you know some of my
jokes are a little off color I said I
don't but like what am I gonna say I
don't I don't mind but it's also not
something I like am used to hearing my
doctor
say are you [__] crazy is he a good
doctor he's missing the tooth listen for
some reason you always know how to pick
winners whether it's doctors H how am I
supposed to know where to find
you know you always kind of byy the way
you're the guy that ate chicken wings of
the 50 Cent concert so you chicken
fingers and that was a good call that
was the best Call of my night that's
even worse chicken fingers at a 50 Cent
conert first off very
racist I didn't make I didn't make the
menu I just ordered it you could had the
avocado toast with the rest I have
avocado toast in
Connecticut I don't know what to tell
you Lee a do with a missing [__] toot
yeah now why didn't he shove he took the
blood out today he check I'm 40 yet he
he checked my vital my my surprisingly
my blood pressure was okay I was [__]
worried about that um he took the blood
he's gonna you know we're gonna meet but
I don't know if I can go back let me ask
you a question did you go to one of
those quick centers no I went to like
that's the thing when since I moved back
from La like I have I have insurance I I
went to like an actual doctor I went to
like a doctor website to try to find
like the reviews and he had all five
star reviews did did they have a picture
of him it did but he had the tooth at
that point they always try to trick I
got catfished by my doctor doctor with a
missing tooth I had a doctor with a Coke
addiction he was a great [__] doctor
I used to just bump into him in the city
at night and he'd be as coked up as I
was and
[__] was he still your your doctor
wasn't it was it your childhood doctor
or like another doctor yeah he was my
childhood doctor all the way to like I
went to Colorado oh uh he was my doctor
till 85 I was trading them eight balls
for steroids at the end for a
prescription of anavar from my friends
and I get them to give me an eightball
and I give it to the
doctor but were you still going to him
as like an actual patient or was he just
to get steroids I was going to him as a
patient but I also bumped into him at
night and to him and I said my friends
needed steroids and he goes come on by
didn't it make you nervous getting like
a shot from him if he's on coke
always maybe that's why you're afraid of
needles one time he shot me with Coke
when I was like bouncing off [__] W
for
hours holy [__] hold on real quick let
me give a shout out to DraftKings and
when I get back I'll tell you that story
all right we'll be right back with you
[__] the Super Bowl is coming hey
what's going on looking for a super
offer for Super Bowl 58 Uncle Joey's got
it for you and it's draft King sports
book the official sports betting partner
of the NFL has your cover here you go
ready new customers get on board for the
big game and I'm GNA let you turn five
bucks into
$200 instantly in bonus bets I love
DraftKings it makes everything more
exciting and what's more exciting than B
58 from Vegas but you can't get there
because you're a mutage so what's the
second best thing you download the app
Draft Kings use code Joey and I'm Gonna
Get You new customers you're gonna get
five bucks and get 200 instantly in
bonus bet but not just that once you
download the app everything's going to
change you're G to become a Savage and
especially Sunday for the Super Bowl
forget about it your friends are going
to have onion dipped no [__] humus
allow in the Super Bowl it's an American
[__] sport all right they're going to
have pork chop whatever the [__] your
friends are going to have you're going
to add excitement because you're going
to have DraftKings and they're going to
come to you and DraftKings has prop bets
overs unders totals whatever you need
DraftKings got it for you this Sunday
for the Super Bowl so do yourself a
favor download the draftking Sportsbook
app right now and press in code Joey Jo
OE y new customers can bet five bucks to
get 200 instantly in bonus bets all
right that's only a draft kicks an
official sport betting partner of Super
Bowl 58 at DraftKings the crown is yours
now listen they want me to read
disclaimers and stuff the little video
tape's gonna come on and some guys G to
talk to you I ain't got time to talk to
you about West Virginia and all that
stuff all right enjoy download the app
at DraftKings and knock yourself out
gambling problem call 1800 Gambler or
visit 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 hopy or text Hopey 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
8887895118
hours after issuance see dk.com foot for
eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms or responsible gaming resources
we're back like her pie all right when I
was like I didn't I moved to New Jersey
when I was 10
1973 but before that I lived on 88th
Street and I still remember
being let's say
six okay okay and that's when doctors
used to make house calls for 35 [__]
bucks they would come house because my
friends used to make house calls so they
get a doctor's note and then go back to
school
when I was growing up you need a
doctor's note for everything if you
played hookie you needed a doctor's note
so doctor's notes were big they were a
flat
25 if the doctor came to your house to
ride it was
35 that's not bad that's a complete
different animal I'm just trying to
educate the [__] audience here right
so so
uh he would come over I knew him his
name was Orlando
Dr
dovali and I still remember him coming
over you know sticking the
[__] thermometer under my tongue and
then checking my lungs and then taking
his glasses off and going oh
anonio a temperature this is what's
going on I'll give you a shot and it'll
be over by tomorrow and right there is
when I would start I don't want a shot
and my mother would start shut the [__]
up you're getting a shot I I don't want
a shot I'm not it's going to hurt I
don't want a shot it's going to hurt and
that's where would I would just say it's
going to hurt in Spanish over and
over say over like a [__] Cuban
[__]
so I would say to them why don't you go
outside for 10 minutes let me think
about
it and they would go out and then my
mother would offer him something to eat
and a
beer and then my stepfather would be
there with these [__] idiots and
another friend and they'd be out there
drinking he come back like a half hour
later are you ready for the drink now at
this age I already knew my my parents
were doing something creepy because I
was in the bathroom putting [__] in
their
nose her friends I knew something was
going up with that [__] in your nose I
just didn't know what it was and then
when he would tell me I'm gonna come
back in 20 minutes and he wouldn't come
out I'd go out to the living room to see
what was going on and obviously there'd
be a piece of aluminum foil on the table
and Orlando would be doing bumps with my
mom and Nelson and [__] you know and
next thing you know he'd come into the
room all [__] banged up and they have
to give me a shot two hours later he was
hammered and I'd sit there my mom would
hold me down Nelson you know the guy who
was a partner at the dry cleaner my
stepfather would grab one leg and they'd
shoot me in the ass and then he leave my
mom a penicillin bottle and a
syringe [__] Cas and then the next day
my mom would shoot me so I'd be walking
around for a week with two purple
[__] ass cheeks one on the right and
one on the
left I knew that guy forever and uh it
ended bad because he had a son my age
who was stealing his
prescriptions okay taking him to
discotex and he lost his license I spoke
to him maybe 15 years ago he was in
Miami at a bar with a friend of who I
haven't spoken to in a year this guy I
think he's
dead but what are you going to [__]
do but anyway that night Saturday I
always felt very disappointed because
you were playing the goou the doju of
Comedy from what I hear it's a great
Club you liked it it was fantastic uh
Matt whatever his name was Bren her was
at bananas and he had invited me up and
I could have gone up down Friday and
gone to hang out with you Saturday but I
was like it's first time featuring there
if I go there they're going to want me
to go
up I'm not going to ruin I'm not going
to let Lee have his [__] night then
Tom Sr was in Atlantic City I could have
gone down there and done 10 minutes in
front of 2,000 people but I opted to go
to Black Betty's in [__] boy New
Jersey what I didn't know is the strip
club was in the basement it's a strip
it's a it's a strip bar right The Comedy
Room is in the basement it seats like 20
people
maybe 20 people could stand you know I
didn't know this I had never been there
I had never known Black Betty existed I
went there a couple Thursdays ago
because they have an open mic on
Thursday okay and I was kind of scared I
pulled into the parking lots right off
the [__] 9 North I pulled into the
parking lot and I saw a rat run across
and I kept thinking about that ACDC song
Night Prowler a rat runs down the alley
and a chill comes down your spine
I'm like you know what I ain't going in
there and I remember my call yesterday I
went and I didn't see any Comics it's
because it's
downstairs oh it was that place got it
so you don't even have to walk to the
strip club so I my I didn't know if I
was going for
sure I knew I wanted to get out of the
house Saturday night and because I
didn't I
I I couldn't get out Thursday night they
canceled the show in Point Pleasant I
couldn't do anything Friday night I had
my daughter
and then Saturday I said [__] it I got
to do something and Dan Florentine Uncle
Dan called me he goes I'm over here at
the comedy show of my wife at the strip
club I'm like what the [__] are you
doing to a strip club EXA downstairs he
goes it's not upstairs it's
downstairs you know I went there and I
saw a lot of young
comics and it was exactly what I wanted
from a room oh cool it was like it why
did I like it because it was very easy
for me go hang out with you a Bren ER
with an audience that 90% would know me
or it would be even nicer to go to AC
and be in the green room and eat food
and come out and do 2,000 people I could
have done that but right now I don't
need that right what I wanted to get
away from I need to get inspired you
know and if anything that inspires you
more is the basement of a strip
club inspiration that you either got to
get fck Mone or you're going to be stuck
at the basement for the rest of your
life and I got to tell you I went to see
my friend Christy Miller I've known
chrisy from The Comedy Store from 97 she
opened up for Paul Mooney she was also a
disciple of Paul Mooney when we hug and
I hugged her I whispered in the
ear if you shake your family tree a
black man will fall out we F we almost
fell
over but she said something that night
that was very very true I watched
another comic go up I watched her go up
I saw a comic that had been doing comedy
for two months go up and I saw a guy had
been doing comedy for like six weeks go
up wow
and I said what else do you have tonight
she goes nothing she goes I could have
done a spot at the New York comedy club
or something but she goes you know what
these little room sometimes it's where
the magic
happens and she was right she it's
because you have no expectations and
there's nothing to be wor like why do
you think the magic happens
there remember I used to what's the
square root of
standup I don't know it's you making the
audience laugh okay with no what's the
square root of it it's it's it's me
after Jiu-Jitsu class with you and eight
other guys just laughing on the mat
about I got beat up this guy got me in
an armar Lee Lee's got the Hitler foot
you
know you know that is the beginning of
standup is us at a pizza parlor when
we're 14 and we're talking about our
mother or our brother or that [__]
kid that has the shop right sneakers and
then I I graduated to a
bus I was on a bus for two years telling
stories with kids going up and down in
the morning and at night busting junkies
balls you know and then it just got
bigger your audience gets bigger and
then you're in front of then you're on a
stage and the first time I got on stage
it was a 100 people on stage the next
night there was 35 people on stage and
like a week later I was back down to
four you know my point is the square
root of Comedy is you coming to get
entertained and me making you laugh
regardless of who's
there you went to the movie
theater they were sold out for the movie
you wanted to see the next one wasn't
starting till [__]
10:40 but the comedy club is starting at
8:30 let's see who's there there's no
YouTube right there's no Tom sagur
there's no Joe Rogan there's no Dave
Chappelle it's just a guy you never saw
before
and you go in there to get
entertained it's so cool that people
come out to shows like that because I
would never think to go to a show like
that but like I I'm so thankful that
people come out to shows like that
listen there's people that like to go to
mass Square Garden there's people that
love to
go to an arena there's people who love
to go to Rascals or the stress Factory
or Uncle Vines uncle
dins but at the same time there's people
who just want to go to a bar sometimes
they really don't want to buy two
drinks you know maybe they don't
drink right this but the bottom line is
they went there to get [__]
entertained and not you know dog I could
tell you a thousand things everybody I
saw that
night they were rocking they really were
the first stripper that came downstairs
the cocktail waitress
right scared the [__] out of me cuz her
suit her stripper suit was as real as it
got she had spiderweb suit with a little
cup holding her little monkey and two
little things on her tits and it was
wrapped around with strings and [__] she
was good-look at one time you know like
she still look good no I'm not no no no
you can tell the way you said it was
very funny she was like something hot in
high schoolo yeah and she had a kid
started drinking maybe did
things worked out the way they did but
she looked good she was there she had
the spider suit on I was like [__] oh I
didn't know if it was topless I didn't
know but they were waitresses or they
were dancers who would come down to
waitress in between their sets to make
extra
money it was uh surreal man but it was
real comedy I got in that car and I felt
so good about myself because I could
have gone anywhere yeah but I went to a
place that I could have got
covid you know that's how many people
were in a small
space and the whole time I'm like this
is what comedy was and I'm looking at
these young guys and I'm like that was
me 30 years ago what is it
24 30 that's 94 yeah once I got the
grasp of it like I told you my first two
years I didn't no dick once 94 came I
started timing my set and writing little
tags and you know it takes time you know
so now like you made it
to
I almost the top I think the like at the
highest the highest for
standup when like look look do you
regret not doing more of those rooms
like when you were doing like when you
were doing it full-time like should I
should people keep doing rooms like that
their whole career what the little rooms
yeah well you saw me at the fourth wall
with you right which is a unique like
most people wouldn't do that either and
I was had spots at the store and at
Flappers and
whatever you know people could do
whatever they want to do man but I I
think once you you're at the Green Room
at the comedy store and you're one of
the guys and you're getting 20 minutes
and you're allowed to bump and you've
done movies and stuff like that it's not
about that anymore it's about like I
made a statement on Rogan a couple weeks
ago I had 2,000 people keep asking me
are you quitting podcasting are you
quitting I didn't say that right I
didn't say that I said that it'd be nice
to do standup with nothing else on your
plate no acting no [__] podcasting no
social media just tight for a year get
on stage 350 nights how many how many
days in a year 3 365 yeah 350 I'm going
for 350 spots if I do a double in a
night it counts as
one really
okay and you know for a year focus on
that with nothing else on my mind just
stand up you're going to a comedy boot
camp that you're [__] teaching you're
at a level in your career where you
could you have the discipline to do that
anybody
does anybody does
Ari's kind of doing that right now don't
you think I mean he he he's a guest on
podcast sometimes but he kind of get he
doesn't do his podcast anymore and he's
he's doing a theater tour right now
listen it's uh you know we've you know I
talked to him all the time about
little and we've discussed it just at
one point in your career I mean listen
bro I've been doing it now 30 something
years I have nothing to prove to nobody
I really don't right what what do I have
to prove you want me to go on an arena
tour to prove to everybody that I'm on
the top that's not the top of your game
right not ever the top of your game
that's just another Avenue that's opened
up for you on the way up you know which
is tremendous I think it's a an amazing
[__] feat but I didn't want to pack
18,000 people in there I don't know it
just
doesn't something about it I'm still in
love with the small room Lee 34 years I
cut the money in quarters I'd rather do
the small room where you feel them
they're on top of you I don't know I'm a
[__] old man what the [__] do I know
but I know that people doing Madison
Square Garden like it's nothing
now yeah they really like I think
Sebastian has like six or seven days
there t coming up shows good killed Tony
two shows yeah it's that's impressive as
[__] and I would love to do manad Square
Garden I just don't have the energy to
come up with 18,000 people at this point
in my life you know I wish I did that's
that's a year of me [__]
curating right A year of me curating and
that's really a year of me Cur rating
because I would have to do sets in
Philly and [__] and Jersey I couldn't do
them in the city I'm gonna be there in
September I'm gonna be October I'm gonna
be there in so trust me there's a
there's always a plan you know it's
interesting that you said like you'd
love to do Madison Square Garden when
you when you were like a a young comic
were there any clubs I know you you used
to talk about circling in the newspaper
but like when you were starting what
what clubs or places did you like really
want to
do
Carolines
okay the Houston laptop
any club in La IGG be's The Comedy
Store the Laugh Factory the ice
house uh the comedy magic club the
before you got there years before you
got there there was a club in the valley
that guy was a thief it was a nice
little workout
room there was one room that stuck
out and it was so weird
that when I had the opportunity to go
there I went there because of that room
there was something I always loved about
the Comedy Underground in
Seattle oh yeah was that there when you
were there yeah oh please that was there
3,000 years before I started comedy okay
but the other clubs I wanted to work you
know when I got into comedy the
newspaper
publication came out out of San
Francisco okay so it highlighted a lot
of stuff in San
Francisco and then when things happened
the clubs that survived with a
punchline the one on the Fisherman's
Warf um not the Improv or the really
great Club I always bomb at it oh uh
cobs Cobbs there was a bunch of clubs up
there I wanted to get my name on you
know but San Francisco was one of those
cities that had like this unbelievable
[__] club scene and hit right when it
was they did a national Contest out of
there and you know Comics the headliners
in in San Francisco made money because
people came out to see him and support
their and they played Oakland like Mark
Curry and they played you know [__]
San Francisco and Concord and all those
Walnut you know there was a punch line
in Walnut Creek for a while that I got
to play at and bomb four shows very
early I'm always very grateful that that
club closed
down
because the haunts the [__] ghost of
my bombing would still haunt me over
there that's how bad I [__] bomed oh
no were you very early on very early on
it was uh three years in I was not
prepared the comic liked me so he
brought me with him and I just
made a fool of myself oh then he gave me
a chance a year later and that club fell
in love with me and I worked that club
three weeks at a shot for
years wow
and I was just thinking about about that
this week because people always ask me
like oh will you come here what like I'm
at a point where like I would love to do
really
anywhere and but there are like a few
clubs that like you know it was just
like what being in New York like seeing
like the stand and the comedy Celler and
like I was myo I I just took a walk my
uh Hotel was right next to Gotham just
place like places I went to as a kid it
just it just like would be amazing and I
would like I said I would love to do
anywhere it's not against any other club
but just seeing like I had dinner at the
place above the cellar just and I've
heard Comics talk about like hanging out
there and so it's just it's it's weird
how like these places have an aura
now it's you know I didn't like the
dinners at places I was too broke to
have dinners at places but there were a
lot of comedy clubs that I wanted to
perform at for personal
reasons and uh yeah I wish you know I
got to perform at all the places I
really wanted to yeah I to perform in
like 40 States or something which is
pretty damn [__] good you know and
some of them were the hard one
Montana wyom
Idaho they were [__] hard at that
point in my career but I'm very grateful
for that you know that I had that
toughness you know a lot of them were
Mormon rooms you didn't know till you
got there in Utah and [__] like that but
the comedy clubs yeah and I got the
headline the ones I wanted to which was
a dream come true because I was so stuck
at feature for so many years and then I
really wanted to work at
headlining so yeah I was good I was very
good trust me what I had to work with I
did way better than other people with
what they had to work with and I had age
against me I had looks against me I had
[__] you know I always with shitty
agents till the end but I always outwork
my people you got to outwork the people
that are working for you to let them
know that type of character you
are right that's basically it
man that's this is all about this is
what your journey is All About Food For
Thought
okay I watched one of his tapes the
other day one of his
uh things came up on Instagram talking
about Mitch Hedberg okay and I really
thought about Mitch for a little while
like I remember him up in Seattle with
Char Hogan and
then later on the Mitch you know things
got bad and whatever but the Mitch I
remember from Seattle 95
96 97 and one of the things he did that
I wish I would have
done that I always dreamt about right on
your own
terms is
go rent yourself a [__]
van you could do for a
month and plan out a route where you
could hit a comedy
club every [__]
night that sounds awesome okay and I
mean you know you're gonna start in
Jersey you're gonna go through
Pennsylvania go to
Michigan the problem is if you do it in
the
summer all the clubs Clos down because
business you know it slows down right
but if you plan a perfect two-month trip
two months it's not about money this is
an investment in you renting a van
mediumsized van you can put a little
cotton there a little Puerto Rican
shower in the back enough clothes to you
know your computer obviously ba and you
put it on like Allah Doug stanh hope
right and you do from [__] New Jersey
pa uh Michigan's got a lot of
comedy you go through Iowa
maybe I don't know I don't know what you
want to do and then come back and after
that like you leave and you you've
created so many
leads if you're gone for 20 day if
you're gone for 60
days and you hit 40
clubs 10 of them aren't going to like
you right but 30 of them are going to be
in contact with you and even if 10 book
you you get your money back not now but
in five years from now because you've
already planted your flag in these
cities which are obviously very hard to
grow
at yeah it's that was always like
I'm I I looked into it when we came back
from LA because like that I don't know
if you've heard like people talk about
van life but people are living in RVs
and vans so you could the the hard part
for me would be getting into actual
clubs like I could I think it would be a
little easier to like you know do
throughout the week do open mics and
then try to match it up with like a club
no my name is Le
sayat I'm working with a guy that's
gonna help me and call these clubs and
go he's coming
through if he could just do a guest set
in your Club you know what we have an
opening that night what does does he
have 45 minutes yeah you're going to get
a couple gigs but most of them you're
going to go in there with a clean
mind your set is just to go in there and
destroy him and make a
contact right people GNA like you
they're going to go wow nobody comes
through here no more that's a forgotten
art people don't want to do that no more
I love doing that I would book a room
somewhere to purposely get a guest set
at a different
place really yeah I wasn't just setting
on the 100 I wasn't going there I was
going to lose money anyway right you're
giving me 75 bucks to come do you one
nighter and [__]
whatever but I'd always call the club
and see if I can I come in early and do
Friday night
yeah I it's crazy that you're saying
this because I'm doing that next month
I'm doing a couple shows in uh Minnesota
and I'm I'm getting to go to act me uh
so but it's um let me ask you this
because you're just talking about like
showing up at clubs like that when
you're when you were doing shows did you
ever
like when did you start working on stuff
at Big Shows cuz like I was talking with
another comic this weekend about it and
we're at a place right now where like
we're just doing like the the A-list
like the on we know will work we want
the clubs to know that we're actually
funny vers versus like working on stuff
in
between dog you were around me for a
long time I'm not going up on stage
unless I drop something on them right
always trying something even the
idea okay the idea like the idea
something happened last night or
something
that you know I don't know something I
wrote it down just the idea I don't have
a joke for it but I know there's
something there wow go through it and
even if it's a throw away the world is
going as [__] look this that and then
throw that joke away and I guarantee by
you just mentioning that you're going to
get three people going to giggle because
they saw the
news from there you know
Lee your goal every night is to be funny
okay you know what's working and you
know what's not if you got 14 minutes of
solid [__]
material you really have 30 but your
first 14 of fire don't book a guest set
for 20 minutes book a GU [__] 10
where you could fit the 14 in and
Destroy them this is the kind of [__]
that you have to look at
objectively and go what do I really have
to offer this joke about this is
fluff it's funny though when I was
watching those young open micers the
other
night I did find something I was saying
to myself throw that joke away to them
no I would never say it to them I would
say say to them personally but about
them to myself right I would throw that
joke away I would throw that joke away I
would take that joke and add this to it
like I was saying that to myself
constantly there something there but I
was saved after the end it's a little
too blw up front like I was doing that
just to and that's what I wanted to do
oh cool to Basics you want to get back
to B I'm not there putting anybody down
no I didn't think that at all nothing
bothered me more that when I was doing
comedy three years there was always that
one guy that came over uh yeah you know
I just opened up for Ron White you
shouldn't use that
joke you know I did it at the Improv
they didn't want to I hear it cuz you
suck you
didn't so I'm not there to ever like I I
sh I tend away from that [__] with
everybody because that's I I know I
don't like people mecking around with it
no I never thought you would would talk
[__] about someone I I didn't know if
you were like thinking about your own
jokes or if you were thinking about
their jokes but that's that's really
cool that like you you found like so I
guess are you close a halfway done with
these 10 sets is like I would say you're
probably maybe even past it I think I'm
on five or six how's it like overall is
it going the way you wanted it to go
like how is it looking yes it's going
the way I wanted it to go ABS [__]
lutely I took my time I didn't force
anything I didn't go anywhere where I
didn't belong I might do something
Wednesday night to help a friend out and
to go check out this club and that'll be
my first lurking night you know that I
lurk outside my
usual Thursday I got somewhere to go
this week I got two places to go nice
and then uh yeah you know I'm always
looking man if something fits boom I
I'll show up and do
10 you know but I can't put myself in
like weird positions either what do you
mean by
that but the end night as I was leaving
20 of those open micers wanted pictures
and I'm like guys oh yeah comedians
knock the [__]
off I'm not sitting here this is the
[__] you do when you get paid for a show
right you know I'm not gonna be out here
for an hour I gotta go home the
honeymoon is just starting Le's coming
over and that's the truth I had a go I
didn't know if you would con your way I
didn't know if you going to call me when
you were in the neighborhood I didn't
want to bother you so but uh no it's
definitely going how I wanted to go go I
think the fourth set I did a little
stutter
step okay home and I'm catching the like
the other the other that had a great set
at the strip club there was one thing I
mumbled there was one thing as I was
doing it I go I'm [__] it up it's a
good premise I gotta go into it a little
better and I came home and worked on it
that night so it's working out great it
would have been it would have been nice
to see Tom and Matt fullron right great
to see brenon would have been great to
see you on stage your natural
habitat but at the same time I gotta get
this handled and the quicker I get this
handled the quicker I can make different
moves
yeah like I said Rogan I could see
myself doing a
residency something really
cool uh but that's it I'm not trout
there's oh yeah I don't I don't expect
you to Trav it just there's places that
I do miss you know oh yeah yeah yeah I
would love I'm definitely going back to
JRE like well not to do the podcast but
to try those three nights I'm definitely
goingon to try it and I always like
going to Milwaukee one more
time I like a Fed World Tour I got some
cities picked I and they're not even
theaters even if it's a couple I hit two
nights I don't know if I could do a late
show anymore Lee you don't think so I
think you I mean it it what is it about
it that that you're not sure is it I
give you energy yeah I want to give you
150% a sleepy Joe is not a good Joe you
know what I'm saying we already have a
sleepy
Joe I know I could come out and give you
one good [__] show right i' rather do
that than give you one really good one
and one Med medal one because are you
feeling tired at the end of your
headlining
like you know what man I don't like I
respect professional athletes uhhuh
because they got to go cold during
commercial
breaks they gotta go cold I hate going
cold after your first
show you get off stage you go in the
Green Room maybe you get something to
eat maybe you smoke a joint you go to
the bathroom you throw some water on
your face and you still got 45 to an
hour to wait right okay got it you sit
down you're talking to your friends
people come into the Green Room you're
talking to them your muscles get tight
your back gets tight I know when I was
doing two shows a night I would get back
to my room and I figured this out why my
legs were so tight at the end of Once I
would go back to my hotel
room I I why am I so tight and then I
figured get out because when you're on
stage your feet clamp into the stage
you're protecting your boundaries you
don't know you're doing this this is the
unconscious [__] you do as part of you
stand up you know I would always stand
one leg at like a guard attack I'm not
gonna stand with both feet even because
that's how Frank Mia got Brock
Lesnar you always got to stand with one
foot in front of the other one
low I would go back to my room I would
go what the [__] and then I started
lifting weights and I figured out why I
was so sore very interesting you know I
wear whoop when I go on stage now very
interesting what you find out about
yourself oh I'm sure if you do 30
minutes if you do 30 minutes or more
with the whoop on okay it becomes an
activity oh okay it pops up by itself
and they'll go what's this activity and
you put standup comedy and then it proc
processes and when the results come back
you're going to go what the [__] was
that your heartbeat was at 90% of your
usual range when you doing this exercise
like what are you talking about you
burned 800 calories 400
calories you don't it's not like I'm
lifting weights on stage I'm breathing
my heart's beating yeah and I'm be there
I'm living
it I'm living it and that's why you burn
800 [__] calories in 45 minutes I
could throw punches for an hour and not
burn 700 calories I go to [__]
Jiu-Jitsu I gotta roll 10 times to burn
700 calories yeah Josh Josh switches
shirts in between shows because he like
sweats yeah I don't sweat no more I
don't do drugs
so when I was doing coke I was sweating
up a [__] storm out there but n I'm
all right now what do you got this week
beautiful this week I'm going to the
Buffalo helium Thursday through Saturday
with Josh oh that's a good time they
don't have the beef on Wick no more and
I think they took the Wings off the menu
at the club yeah okay you know where you
gotta go oh yeah I'm excited there yeah
there's there's duffs and then like
there's a couple of them out there
you're not going bar that's where a many
gun's going okay no more Anchor Bar the
wings Wen start that's where the wings
started but you're not go drive by beep
the horn show some you know what I'm
saying I can't wait I'm excited for
Buffalo bu great make sure you use Josh
as a reference the other Josh Buffalo
Josh Potter yeah Potter the Man of Steel
oh yeah and oh yeah I that's one of the
ones that I'm excited like I'm excited
about all of them but I've heard you and
like a lot of comics talk about the
Buffalo helium for years I like it I
just read some comic went up there and
it was awful and I'm like I don't know
what this guy's a primadana I don't know
what comic it was I've always enjoyed
the Buffalo crowds always yeah they're
great they'll take the ride with you
they're not politically correct you know
if it's real Buffalo you'll be fine and
buffalo is always Buffalo it don't
change I'm so
pumped it's gonna be great let me I
don't know where I'm going to be but I'm
going to be out twice this week you know
trying some stupid jokes just
it's made me a better person recently
just getting out getting in the car you
know getting high driving stopping at
Wawa it's good for the soul you know so
I'm doing great with it brother but yeah
with
February I don't know how many dates you
got this
month I got a couple things going on oh
yeah well you want I have a I have uh uh
I think this is it actually I think I I
have two weeks free right now but the
Buffalo one's a big one what else do you
have I don't have any shows I just got
you know oh okay no I got no shows I'm
just going off the seat of my
pants I feel like tonight's too cold I
wouldn't go anywhere to do comedy
tonight oh no n it's too cold tonight
it's Monday night what's going on ain't
nothing going on unless I go into the
city I'm not going into the city to my I
gotta go there tomorrow and then
Wednesday I gotta be at the doctor at 9:
I got a hell of a [__] week
[__] but I'll be and I'll be in
touch with you little
bastards what do you want me to say I
don't [__] know I love you
[__] thank you for watching the
checkin today we're gonna keep
pushing that's it now to our sponsors
[Music]
back
the checkin is brought to you by Blue
chw listen guys it doesn't matter how
old you are good sex is good sex blue
chw is here to make it awesome every
time blue chew is online service that
sends chewable tablets right to your
door with the same active ingredients is
Viagra Calis and Levitra at half the
cost take a tablet anytime day and night
so you're always ready to get the party
started let me tell you something I love
these because you they come individual
pouches you can put them in your little
wallet and when it's time to sling
you're always prepared you're like a
[__] General your cannons loaded you
know what I'm saying everything is done
online with blue Chu no awkward doctor
visits no waiting in line at the
pharmacy blueo packaging is discret but
your package will be
unmistakable
so do me a favor blueo wants to help you
have better sex discover your options at
blu.com chew it and do it here's the
special deal for checkin listeners try
blue chew for free when you press code
Joey j o e y at checkout again free when
you press code Joey at checkout and just
pay $5 for shipping that's
blue.com promo code Joey to receive your
first month free visit blu.com for more
details and important safety information
and thank you Blu for sponsoring the
podcast listen if you don't know about
Blu get your [__] together all right
your dick will be as hard as these
missiles they're sending over there
you'll be making everybody very [__]
happy including Mama the cat whatever
whoever wants it now the Checker is also
brought to you you
buy the freeze pipe listen when you when
we're done with looking stupid and
getting coughin attacks every time we
smoke cut the [__] out with freeze pipe
why you want to look like Lee you ever
see Lee smoke the old bangets he's
fumbling he's spitting and [__] not what
freeze pipe he doesn't freeze pipe is
tremendous they make freezable pipes
bubblers and bongs and more that cool
smoke down by over 300 Dees I got one in
the garage right now I got the [__]
chamber in the freezer with the meat and
the Italian ises I go out there I change
the water I put my piece in there I
grind up my [__] death reefer and
next thing you know baboom just pop that
baby in the freezer for an hour and then
smoke passes through the chamber it
instantly cools down you won't be
coughing your eye won't come out and
when people come over you'll be the best
host in town and have one ready when
company's over American owned with over
a 100,000 100,000 happy customers freeze
pipe is your solution to smoke like
royalty without paying a king's Ransom
shop right now at the free pipe.com
again the free pipe.com pressing code
Diaz D AZ I'm Gonna Get You 10% off your
entire order and that's a big number
these days that's the free pipe.com Cod
Diaz for 10% off order today and get
free shipping and say goodbye to killing
your lungs forever